hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel with today I am dying my hair
myself at home there are like a few
things that I want to talk about before
we do this one sorry it does echo
naturally I made a bathroom maybe you
don't bleach you have anywhere other
than a bathroom good tip also I just
wanted to make a quick note of why
people ask me why do you dye your hair
which feels like a weird question to be
asked but I still get asked a lot I do
have a genuine answer for why I'm
extremely plug Pro bleach my head gets
really oily really really really quickly
with this which is my natural color if
it grows out this is the most I've let
it grow in quite some time that's
probably about eight weeks and my
forehead has broken out in these pimples
that I otherwise never get it is just
that my hair is really oily and it ruins
my skin so I bleach my hair it prevents
that it's great very helpful for someone
who works on camera but yes bleaching is
one part of this process and then we get
into how I get the actual sylva color
that I have but where the bleaching is
concerned I don't really want to show
you very much about this or tell you how
to do it I will 100% tell people exactly
how I get the Silvo that's the question
I get asked more often than not anyway
the bleaching pod is the process of
lightening your hair several shades this
is basically white underneath you have
to do that before you can just put
silver you have to lighten your hair the
process of lightening here involves
chemicals that can burn you burn your
skin and break your hair I don't want to
record that because naturally I know
what works for my hair because I spent a
really long time back in the day
bleaching my hair myself I've done it a
lot but I can't tell you what's gonna
work for yours I don't want to give you
advice on mixing bleach with peroxide
and you using exactly the same stuff as
me and you potentially damaging yourself
or your hair nor do I even really want
to encourage anyone to do this at all
definitely go to a hairdresser if you
can I'm only doing it for mom right now
because hey I have done it a lot before
I'm a little more confident but B I
can't see my hairdresser
I'm stuck at home but basically I
decided that maybe I won't show you the
pot way you mix the chemicals that can
give you chemical bonds and break your
hair until it falls out so I'm not gonna
show you the Lightning pot but the
people who already have really light
hair I will show you how I get my Silva
color and how it stays consistent and
pretty much never washes out clearly
it's been this long since I've been to
the hairdresser but my hair is still
very much this white silver color but it
has been a long time since I've done
this so there's a chance we could fail
oh my god it's orange no really that's
pretty much how it's supposed to be I
bleach ahead to a very yellowy color
which is exactly what's going on right
now but it's quite even so that's good
I did draw it down a bit so it looks
like it's a lot longer than it was just
cuz I had some banding I wanted to clean
up that would isn't going to make sense
to most of you but the pot that the pot
that stops it from being orange is toner
though I technically don't even actually
use toner I use a very specific shampoo
I'll show you just because I feel like
it may not have been obvious in the
framing of the last putt I was not naked
I was wearing a towel cuz I had just
gotten out of the shower
it wasn't weed you didn't see anything I
wasn't thinking about it comments on
that gonna be fun okay
it feels very weird to be showing you
the next part of this well not in the
shower and basically I have hair in my
mouth basically the second that I'm done
even showing you this also I think the
air conditioning tunnel so this extra
background noise this is a great video
like comment subscribe basically the
second I've done and this will be really
quick I jump in the shower wash this out
this is very fast so um
hmm so first up I just put shampoo in my
hair
because my hair is very long and very
blond and got so bad wait
I don't shampoo the ends of my hair I
just condition I just shampoo the top
for anyone who bleaches your best to be
using a sulphate fee free shampoo if you
have the option to but whatever it
doesn't matter what you use
just put your shampoo in your hair like
so oh [ __ ] that's why I then this is so
ridiculous I've never seen what I look
like we should have poo in my head
because I've never done this before then
I get my trusty secret not sponsored at
all I use this this is finola no yellow
its finola no yellow shampoo you can
also use the mask I've used that before
it works just fine this stuff is so
potent I believe it only works if you
have extremely bleached hair I don't
think it works on natural blondes not
positive that's true just what blonde
friends who I suggested this to have
told me um so I'm gonna put this in my
hands I'm gonna rub it in and then
immediately go and wash it out this has
to be so quick this stuff if I leave it
in for 10 seconds too long will turn my
hair purple it's that good but again I
really only do it on the top so we're
just gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna dad to
destroy this show when I [ __ ] rip it
off and run in the shower
r.i.p Rick Sanchez yes that's what we
need to toss it that's it that's it
thick
get that [ __ ] on real fast oh it is a
really pretty pepper would like wouldn't
that be nice I had heavies color
that's it I'm up all right it didn't
work I guess I now have right to call
this video like fail head die in
quarantine or whatever but I'm not gonna
do that
probably basically what happened is my
hair for the most part is a lovely
silver my usual silver also looked
definitive proof that I do not have
extensions people ask all the time but
the roots stayed yellow you can see this
line of a yellow oh boy I guess I
thought that I wouldn't need a toner
because this stuff works so well and it
did work really well it's way less
orange but naively I was wrong
realistically I should have used two
tana part of the problem is that when my
hair has just been dyed it like doesn't
absorb things very well so I'm of two
minds right now I have the option to
leave it for a bit let it grow and keep
using that purple shampoo and eventually
I think this will go away I think or I
need to buy a toner from a stall so my
nail look purple I think I'm gonna let
it grow I don't want to damage it any
more so I'm just gonna have yellow to
silver hair for a while good thing we're
in quarantine I don't care so yeah that
feels good everything's okay on that
front but we do have yellow roots which
isn't the intended effect I should have
known
realistically I knew that I knew you had
to dye your roots I knew it doesn't just
happen that way
I need come on but also I stupid on care
but I actually think probably in a
couple of weeks shampoo we'll just walk
when my hair has had some room to
breathe and gain some nutrients back
post bleach so which we like